[Musica]
oggi non sono qui per insegnarti
qualcosa
sono qui per creare in the un'esperienza
trasformativa per farti sentire che poi
liberati dai condizionamenti
voglio che ascoltare la mia voce apra
dentro di te uno spazio di
consapevolezza
io sono nato a volterra il paese dei
matti lo chiamavano così perché lì c'era
un grande manicomio e da piccolo mi
fermavo per ore a guardare il vuoto fino
a perdermi completamente dei miei
pensieri cercando il senso della vita
certo il mio corpo era lì ma la mia
mente viaggiava velocissima verso
qualcosa che ancora oggi non saprei
definire era attratto da qualcosa di
spirituale di universale poi arrivava
lei si sa certe cose le fanno le mamme
mi risvegliava senza giudicarli senza
farmi domande e mi riportava a casa e
con i piedi per terra
in quei momenti mi sentivo guidato da
un'energia fortissima che mi attraeva ma
allo stesso tempo mi faceva anche
tantissima paura e tu hai paura
quanti di voi hanno paura
io ho sempre paura e direi che grazie
alle mie paure che ho sconfitto tante
delle mie paure
io mi ci butto dentro dalla testa ai
piedi è uno scontro è un incontro con i
miei limiti
è uno scontro incontro con i tuoi limiti
e quanti di voi sono timidi pochi quando
dici io sono timido stai definendo la
tua identità e questo è un limite
stai definendo il tuo ruolo se ti
convinci di essere timido ti comporterai
come una persona timida e magari non
alzi la mano quando ti chiedo di farlo
ho sicuramente non verresti su un palco
come questo
a raccontare i tuoi problemi come sto
facendo adesso io il timido di fatto sta
cercando semplicemente di proteggerti
dallo sguardo e dal giudizio degli altri
sicuramente le categorie definiscono la
nostra realtà spiegando la ma
inevitabilmente limitandola
e alla fine finisce che ci credi davvero
che ne esista soltanto una di realtà di
fatto la realtà non esiste o meglio ne
esistono talmente tante che vederne
soltanto una sarebbe sicuramente
limitante se si è d'accordo con me
quante identità e 6 madre sei figlio sei
un professionista
sei uno studente sei sicura sei forte 6
deciso 6 determinata sei buono ea volte
se anche un po cattiva le categorie ci
danno la sensazione di proteggersi dalla
paura ci sentiamo un pochino più sicuri
ma abbiamo sempre bisogno di dare nomi
alle cose alle persone di chiudere di
racchiudere di etichettare nelle case
nelle nelle strade nelle città nelle
relazioni perché forse troppa libertà
potrebbe trasformarsi in follia e questo
ci spaventa quindi per liberare la tua
identità liquida e funzionale voglio che
tu provi a focalizzare la sua attenzione
su questi tre punti
devi essere consapevole di rituali
condizionamenti quindi attivare la tua
attenzione devi scegliere di liberarti
da queste etichette quindi fare un atto
di volontà
devi scegliere di agire
scegli quindi di seguire una direzione
di seguire una luce un faro che possa
guidarti in questo cammino nel mio mondo
i fari sono due le luci interne e quelle
esterne la luce interna e la
consapevolezza che tu puoi attivare solo
grazie all'esercizio continuo della
meditazione le luci esterne sono i tuoi
mentori le persone che ti hanno
condizionato e influenzato positivamente
nella sua vita sei consapevole quando la
tua attenzione è con te quando sai
esattamente cosa stai facendo
mentre lo stai facendo anche adesso puoi
provare ad essere presente prova a
seguire le mie parole
chiudi gli occhi in questo momento
focalizza la sua attenzione sul tuo
respiro prova a fare questo piccolo
esercizio
adesso se anti la tua schiena appoggiata
su questa sedia
il suono della mia voce che lentamente
diventa più bassa come più lento diventa
il tuo respiro le sue parte vere
potrebbero diventare più pesanti
il suono della mia voce i rumori piccoli
presenti in questa stanza focalizzati su
quello che stai sentendo i chiari sono
appoggiati a terra il contatto con i
suoi vestiti
lascia che tutto questo possa accadere
permettersi di entrare in contatto con
te stesso lascia che tutto questo possa
avvenire nel modo più naturale e
armonico per te e adesso lentamente apri
gli occhi di nuovo e guarda avanti
davanti a te ci sono le tue luci sono
tante sono i tuoi mentori le persone che
ti hanno influenzato positivamente che
con le loro parole con le loro vite
straordinarie con i libri che hanno
scritto con le loro gesta che hanno
permesso di sfumare i confini della tua
identità e di costruire ogni giorno una
nuova identità esistono due tipi di
persone quelle che vivono comodamente
adagiandosi nella loro identità e che
quindi vivono nell'illusione che diventi
ton esista soltanto una e quelle che
come direbbe uno dei miei maestri vivono
pericolosamente quando dico vivere
pericolosamente mi riferisco ovviamente
a rischio psicologico e spirituale sono
quelle persone che si prendono appunto e
di rischio di rompere i propri schemi e
quelli degli altri quelli della società
e quindi anche tu corri il rischio di
essere imperfetto di sbagliare di
rompere gli schemi e talvolta anche le
palle se necessario rischia a gissi
gioca crea fi creativo gioisci per la
realtà che riesce a costruire ogni
giorno
non voglio che questi diventino degli
slogan motivazionali che devi ripeterti
ogni giorno ossessivamente per avere una
vita di successo ma voglio che tu mangi
queste parole
mangia le portale profondamente dentro
di te interiorizza le portale conte fa
le tue vivi pericolosamente da questo
momento lascia che qualcosa prenda forma
dentro di te non sei più la stessa
persona che è entrata in questa stanza
dati modo datti la possibilità lascia
che qualcosa possa accadere
prendi quella decisione fallo quando
esci da qui chiama quella persona ville
tutto quello che non l'hai detto finora
fai quel viaggio virus permettendo va in
quel posto
poni fine a tutte quelle relazioni
tossiche e lascia spazio alle tue
identità io dico sempre che se non
agisci stai trovando delle scuse e sono
certo che tu non vuoi essere una persona
che trova delle scuse
e allora permettimi di salutarti così
dicendoti che è ciò che facciamo oggi
che determina chi saremo domani
[Applauso]
[Musica]